I'll show you how we can add breakpoints
in our code go ahead and click on the
screen bug icon to attach the debugger
we'll go to the settings menu in the
settings activity I'm going to add two
break points in the on preference change
method I'm going to add a breakpoint at
line 59 in the case of a list preference
when it's about to set the summary I'm
also going to add a breakpoint at line
63 when it's not a list preference and
it sets the summary let's go into the
app to try it out tap on the location
and change the postal code if you hit OK
then it triggers a breakpoint to stop it
right here these are the values of the
variables at this time and we see the
new postal code here you can step over
or into the method for more details or
you can hit play to continue or stop to
stop the debugger let's hit play to
continue and then we see that the UI has
been updated so that the preference
summary is the new postal code let's try
it for temperature units we tap here and
then select Imperial it triggers this
breakpoint in the list preference case
we hit play to continue and then we see
that Imperial is now the preference
summary